Previously on startup.
I founded a startup called not fine.com where you can share 6.1 second videos.
I then brought in through my friends to help me build the most innovative video
platform.
And I met up with Aria who secretly hate each other and constantly compare Dick
size. We just sold the other company. I'm just relaxing.
Now I'm trying to figure out what to do next. Yeah,
I'm excited, but I'm also afraid.
It's just getting really hard, you know,
managing all these relationships at once. It's getting too hard.
What excites you about the relationship you have with your employees? Wait,
what? No, I was talking to my Tinder relationship. God never listen to me,
but to be honest, I just can't get Ari off my mind.
Who's Aria. Oh, he's, he's just some startup founder. Uh,
we recently played chess, chess, startup, founder.
I think it means more to you than that.
We used to be best friends,
but then things changed.
Things really changed.
[Inaudible].
Can you tell me a little bit about your relationship with Joma? You know,
we were friends then best friends, even how'd you guys meet?
He was in the study room, struggling with a simple assignment,
but I knew he was smarter than that. He came up to me, offering his help.
Thank God, because I just couldn't focus.
I was about to give up something else was consuming him.
I could see that he was pretty broken at the time.
So I thought I could bring him under my wing.
I gave him a better place to stay better resources, better contacts,
a better life. Nobody wanted to give them a chance,
but I saw the potential in him.
He was kind to me extremely kind. I didn't serve it.
He let me stay with him in this apartment. She gave me my own room.
He even got me all the textbooks I needed for school.
He really took me out of the times. You know,
even guided me through my academic career without him,
I would have been lost.
He's the reason why I am quiet today from algorithms that
statistics to cryptocurrencies, he taught me everything.
He made sure I knew the right things.
He made sure I succeeded. Okay.
So one thing we can do is with binary search would have been nothing without me.
Oh, it was internships.
He got those through me except Microsoft. That was more him.
That's thoughtful. I wanted the best for him. I really did.
I did everything I could for him until the incident.
What happened should have known so stupid.
I just couldn't face the truth.
I don't know. He's changed.
You speak kind and warm.
But I think one day I just realized that he wasn't self this person.
I thought he was even kicked me out the house.
I mean, I appreciate everything he's done for me. Let me come on, man.
What the was I supposed to call you? Add nothing.
I should know people like him. They don't have people like me.
How did you feel? It was humiliating.
I miss Aria. I really do.
You mean if he had exterior motives to bring me in? I was really happy.
I still don't know what he wanted from me, but offset and have it
just pushed me away. I didn't ask why. I mean,
I didn't deserve his kindness,
but things just got worse and that's where he crossed the line.
Never confronted him about it because it just wouldn't matter.
One is apology. I just want it to break.
Can feel the pain that I felt until he's completely broken,
can regret everything that he did.
All right guys.
So today I paid a consultant to make this video for us.
Um, it's going to tell us, you know, how to think about MVPs. So what's the,
you mean.
Like LeBron wait,
what's the brawn. Oh, he's the MVP.
All right, whatever. All right, let's just play the video.
So the biggest problem that startups run into is creating something that nobody
wants to buy this waste years of work and thousands of dollars only to leave you
broken unemployed, just like a college degree. So to stop this from happening,
I thought I'd go over the concept of an MVP and how this can help you grow your
company. So what is an MVP?
This often gets confused with most valuable player,
but I think that comparison is kind of unfair because if you're trying to start
a startup, chances are you have zero athletic ability.
Instead MVP here. It means a minimum viable product,
a rough version of your idea that takes a minimal amount of effort,
but it's still good enough that users can get a taste of the full product,
similar to how dating someone is sort of a taste of what marriage will be like.
And in my case, I've been told, I tastes like insecurity and an absentee father.
Now, the reason you want to build an MVP is because it lets you learn what your
customers like. And don't like as quickly as possible.
This is a pretty important concept because 90% of startups fail because they
have no clue what their customers want.
Like this one time I was sitting at McDonald's and thought of a really good app
idea, it involved a dating app where girls would choose guys based only on their
personality and finally give nice guys a fighting chance.
But then I asked myself, would I date someone based only on the personality?
I'll let you decide now. I'm sure you're wondering what an MVP looks like.
The answer to that depends on what you're trying to build.
So I thought it'd be helpful to show a few real life examples.
Let's say you wanted to build an app where people could store and share files
online. You could do one of two things. One,
quit your job and spend years trying to make the app yourself or to hire someone
to create a 32nd video of what that app would look like and show it to investors
for millions of dollars while option one sounds attractive. The MVP here is too.
And that's what Dropbox did. Well.
Let's say you want it to figure out if a girl or guy liked you.
Your MVP here would be a small, low pressure invite. Like, Hey,
I'm going out to dinner with friends. Do you want to come along?
We're grabbing pizza, smiley face. And a few things can happen here. One,
she won't respond to you too. She says something short like haha,
or LOL or three. She says, no, I thought I told you,
I'm not interested when this happens.
You might try to convince yourself that she's still into you,
but chances are she is into you. So just wait a few days and try again.
So by now you're probably wondering how to actually build an MVP.
And that's exactly what I'm going to show you. Now,
the steps I'll be outlining my team simple at first,
but there's a bit of math involved, so you'll need to pay close attention.
And just before we start,
I thought I should mention that these steps are approved by the international
board of startup venture capitalists,
which means rest assured it's coming from a source of authority.
So without further ado,
here are the steps to building your first MVP step one don't we have enough
startups.
So I hope that was helpful and best of luck in your startup journey.
All right. So what do you guys think.
We need to start off by building our backend infrastructure.
We can leverage Amazon CDNs load balancers and Lambdas modularize our
infrastructure by using microservices so that we can set up elastic scaling and
save money. I don't think we should do that.
This the most cost efficient solution. Well,
we don't even know if we're going to get that many users. It's a total overkill.
Yes. It might save some capital,
but development time is our most limited resource and we can't waste time
thinking about scalability on an MVP right now, our most limited resources,
my patients with your ideas,
why can we just have a Facebook page and let people post their videos there and
see if that grows. That's actually a really good,
good and smart MVP. But for the sake of this web series,
we have to do something more complicated. All right.
So here's what we're going to do. Wait, what do you have the final thing?
Because I went to Waterloo.
All right. Here's the thing. So as an MVP,
we're just going to make a purely consumption site.
The reason why is because we want to validate if there's actually demand for our
website. So that's why we're just going to make a simple weapon.
What we'll do is that we'll pretend that it's invite only to be able to produce
on our platform. But in reality, we don't have a production side,
but we're really going to do it.
It's just that when it's still old find videos and post them on our website,
that way the consumer side will think that we're producing videos using the
mobile app, which is invite them for growth.
We'll have a Facebook page and we'll put only the best of the best find videos
there. And then we'll just boost the out of it with ad credits. All right.
So here's what we need.
We need someone to build the whole web app front and backend.
We don't have enough resource to separate them.
That's why we need someone to own the whole full stack. I'm on it. All right.
He wants to ride the caller to get all the best find videos and then write
pipelines, funneled them into our website. Got it. John Kane, right?
The fake landing page for the mobile website. And also,
can you set up the CVN so we can survey those faster and I'll manage to Facebook
page and start growing it. All right. Let's do it.
[Inaudible].
All right. What do you think of this?
No, we can't launch that. It looks exactly like, no, this is perfect. All right,
guys, this is really good. All right. So next we're going to be,
I think you might want to look at this.
It's not good.
What's popping. So I hope you enjoyed this episode. Uh,
I definitely had fun making it, so I hope you guys had fun watching it. Um,
I just want to give a shout out to Matthew Cho. He's my new cinematographer.
He's amazing. So I want you guys to check out his stuff because, um,
I don't know. He's probably one of the best photographers I've ever met and uh,
yeah, he deserves a shout out second. Shout out.
I want to shout out to the sinful engineer.
Thank you for giving me that clip about MVP. This guy's hilarious. Yeah.
So you should check that out.
I put as a link on the description and also of course,
I feel like this video and you haven't subscribed to my channel. Subscribe now,
come on where you're waiting for. And uh, yeah.
Thank you so much and see you on the next episode. Peace.